on france in nice last night his
sonata truck drove into the crowd
gathered for the fire nor to crush we
deplore at the moment when I speak 77
victims including several children and about
twenty wounded
the terrorist character cannot be denied
and  once again of
absolute and extreme violence so that we
can master and their families the
terrorist scourge has been killed
we will go to this day if he had
accomplices but we are making sure that
we can put us on his possible tracks
the  france was struck on its
national day on July 14 French
[Music]
are signed by the fans question mrs
wright and that necessarily by the fanatics i
express on behalf of the grieving nation
our solidarity with regard to the victims
and to  their families our express my soul
dancing we help the injured
the white plan which mobilizes all the
hospitals in the region was triggered
after November of last year with
saint denis for the canisse is at  its
turn affected it is the whole of france which
is under threat
whissell 500 in nice
in these circumstances we must
make circumstances of absolute vigilance
yes mask the citizens without fault
many briefcases regard our
legislative arsenal has been considerably
reinforced but we  must, since we
are in a summer period,
further increase our level of
protection also mastering bezina I
am afraid to be a young
secure structure of the forces as from
the inside first of all that we are going to
maintain the level of the
sentinel operation which allows us to  mobilize
10,000 soldiers in addition to the
gendarmes and the police
animations, that is to say where we were in
the gendarmerie staff to
come and relieve the
police staff of the senior executives
we can
I have decided that the state of the game n 6
July would be extended by three months a
bill
will to fight terrorism
and we will further strengthen our
actions in syria as in iraq and we will
continue to strike hard mister you
force indeed announced yesterday morning a
defense council will be held tomorrow
it will examine all the measures that we
have already taken and that i come from
all the necessary personnel in all
the  sites and in all cities where
we need protection and
vigilance
I will go with the prime minister to
nice following this council of defense to
support master all means to
wade me to force afflicted occur
this monstrosity which  consists of the
treated seeds to aim
deliberately killed who came week and
to celebrate my comrades in the shelter of a
match no 3 l and tearful
she is distressed but she is france and
zenacker and some want to
hit her today